so when I do my job people hate me in
fact the better I do my job the more
people hate me and no I'm not a meter
maid
and I'm not an undertaker I am a
progressive lesbian talking head on Fox
News so y'all heard that right just to
make sure right I'm a gay talking head
on Fox News I'm gonna tell you how I do
it and the most important thing I've
learned so I go on television I debate
people who literally want to obliterate
everything I believe in in some cases
who don't want me and people like me to
even exist it's sort of like
Thanksgiving with your conservative
uncle on steroids with the live
television audience of millions it's
totally almost just like that and that's
just on air the hate mail I get is
unbelievable last week alone
I got 230 eight pieces of nasty email
and more hate tweets than I can even
count
I was called an idiot a traitor a
scourge and an ugly man and that was
just in one email so what have I
realized being on the receiving end of
all this ugliness well my biggest
takeaway is that for decades we've been
focused on political correctness but
what matters more is emotional
correctness let me give you a small
example I don't care if you call me a
dyke I really don't I care about two
things one I care that you spell it
right
it's just quick refresher it's d-y Katie
you totally be a surprise and second I
don't care about the word I care about
how you use it are you being friendly
are you just being naive or do you
really want to hurt me personally it
emotional correctness is the tone the
feeling how we say what we say the
respect and compassion we show one
another and what I've realized is that
political persuasion doesn't begin with
ideas or facts or data political
persuasion begins with being emotionally
correct so when I first went to go work
at Fox News true confession I expected
there to be marks in the carpet from all
the knuckle-dragging right that by the
way in case you're paying attention is
not emotionally correct but but liberals
on my side we can be self-righteous we
can be condescending we can be
dismissive of anyone who doesn't agree
with us in other words we can be
politically right but emotionally wrong
and incidentally that means that people
don't like us right now here's the
kicker
conservatives are really nice I mean not
all of them and not the ones who send me
hate mail but you would be surprised
Sean Hannity is one of the sweetest guys
I've ever met he spends his free time
trying to fix up his staff on blind
dates
and I know that if I ever had a problem
he would do anything he could to help
now I think Sean Hannity is 99%
politically wrong but his emotional
correctness is strikingly impressive and
that's why people listen to him because
you can't get anyone to agree with you
if they don't even listen to you first
we spend so much time talking past each
other and not enough time talking
through our disagreements and if we can
start to find compassion for one another
then we have a shot at building common
ground it actually sounds really hokey
to sort of say it standing up here but
when you try to put it in practice it's
really powerful
so someone who says they hate immigrants
I try to imagine how scared they must be
that their community is changing from
what they've always known or someone who
says they don't like teachers unions I
bet they're really devastated to see
their kids school going into the gutter
and they're just looking for someone to
blame our challenge is to find the
compassion for others that we want them
to have us that there's emotional
correctness I'm not saying it's easy an
average of like five point six times per
day I have to stop myself from
responding to all of my hate mail with a
flurry of vile profanities this whole
you know sort of finding a compassion
and common ground with your enemies
thing is kind of like a political
spiritual practice for me and I ain't
the Dalai Lama I'm not perfect but what
I am is optimistic because I don't just
get hate mail I get a lot of really nice
letters lots of them
one of my all-time favorites begins I'm
not a big fan of your political leanings
or your sometimes tortured logic but I'm
a big fan of you as a person now this
guy doesn't agree with me yet
but he's listening not because of what I
said but because of how I said it and
somehow even though we've never met
we've managed to form a connection
that's emotional correctness and that's
how we start the conversations that
really lead to change thank you